Candace starts us off this hour in Miami
merry Christmas to you Candace Merry
Christmas thanks taking my call
sure what's up so what would you do
question my shoes we my my husband has
been involved in a custody battle with
contentious ex who's also an addict for
a while and a guardian ad litem was
assigned to the case and he has you know
was assigned to pay 50% of the guardian
allowance fees however the fees have
racked up so high and we've been making
payments that we can every month but
today in court she says that's not
enough and the judge decided that we
need to pay her in full within 30 days
and it's over 20 thousand dollars and we
don't have any money and I'm just kind
of wondering what would you do in this
situation what did your attorney say to
the judge we can't even afford an
attorney she has 3 we have men the
addict has more attorneys than you have
her parents are billionaires ok and so
they're paying their hat they're paying
their half of her half of the guardian
ad litem yes ok Astra oh hold are these
babies
what is 13 she's with her mom now just
recently and the other one the other one
is 12 and he lives with us full-time and
how long is this going to be ongoing
forever until the for the next six years
I mean I don't know we're really we've
asked for a mediation we've I suspect to
finish this they've scheduled another
date to talk about mediation and our
great a mediation is its I never seen
something so hard it takes months and
months just to get a court date many you
know the Guardian now it might mean
while the guardian ad litem gets paid
every month
yeah and her bill to us so think about
doubling it is it's in the thousands of
dollars a month and we only have a few
hundred dollars a month we could pay her
oh this is what happens when you don't
have an attorney well I don't know the
problem I mean if it was a one-time bill
you have a debt to a lawyer a guardian
at litem and you could just change where
the debt sits and if you if you have the
ability to borrow the money you would go
and borrow it from the credit union you
have a twenty thousand dollar bill at
the credit union instead of a twenty
thousand dollar belt the other that's
not like going into debt you're already
in that then so that doesn't bother me
the thing that bothers me is what are
you gonna do six months from now when
you got to it again yeah or a month from
now when she goes another $2,000 yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying we just
don't make I mean I've been helping out
as much as I can we kept their finances
separate because of the issues but I've
been helping up as I can but you know he
only makes $4,000 a month I don't know
about six okay so you have $10,000 a
month income yeah but we have four
paying all of the one child's expenses
including private school women are taken
out of high school so I mean if you're
going to continue this battle you have
to find $2,000 a month in your budget or
you have to discontinue the battle well
we try to discontinue the battle but
they won't you know we said we want to
like finish this and wrap this up and we
just kind of get told what to schedule
something else for that like we're not
really being given the option to just
what is that the other side wants though
they won't actually tell us I'm guessing
they want the kids back with her and
other things too but I don't think
that's really going to be on the table
as far as even though the guardian ad
litem doesn't love us for not paying
like she agrees that the situation is
better the way it is but i just don't i
think the lawyers on her side are
interested in making as much money as
possible so they have no problem selling
this out yeah yeah well it's also a
strategy to starve you out and it's
working okay well you're going to have
to get legal representation because you
cannot afford to carry this on for three
more years so if we go in more into got
to get legal representation yeah because
you're getting ready go more in debt
anyway every time they send you a bill
you can't pay that's called debt and so
you've got to adjust your budget to be
able to pay this to survive or you've
got to adjust the situation to fit your
budget and that means legal
representation and so you've got to get
a lawyer to go in and have some
reasonable discussions with a judge here
it doesn't surprise me that the judge
wants his guardian or her guardian ad
litem paid that that's logical and
you're not paying is not okay i get that
from the judge's perspective but but the
fact that this thing is tied up and is
running you know that's just running sam
through the glass here or every time i
can't it's untenable
it's just untenable it's not it's not
sustainable so you've got to break the
tie somehow surrendering hiring a lawyer
or adjusting your budget to fit two
thousand dollars a month and that you
adjust your budget by cutting expenses
getting rid of stuff or by whatever i
mean you could tell the guardian at
litem we can either pay the private
school or we can pay you which would you
rather so remove that remove that that
that requirement that the kids in
private school remove that requirement
remove that help me help me help us
somehow get our budget go meet schedule
a meeting with the guardian litem just
sit down show them your budget and go
what would you do how are we supposed to
survive against the billionaire parents
and see if you can get some coaching
here and get or maybe they've got a
suggestion a legal maneuver i don't know
but that would be one thing i could you
could do it
meeting with them and I'd do that today
and just share the situation it's not
that we don't want to pay you it's that
we don't want this to go on forever and
ever number one number two we can't one
of the money so you cuz you got these
requirements put on us on this other kid
so you know you can go that direction
but I don't know how to solve it exactly
but really it sounds like as I go
through it in my mind there's three
possible scenarios surrender adjust your
budget or get legal representation that
causes the situation to be adjusted one
of those three things meantime you've
got twenty thousand dollar bill if you
can borrow that much plus ten more to
get you to lawyer if that's what you
want to do any problem with that because
that's its debt you already have I'm not
telling you to go into debt you're in
the debt you're there it's just a matter
of where the debts it's it's like I've
got credit card debt or I got a card
that and you borrowing your car to pay
off the credit cards there's still the
dad it's still you're just moving the
debt around so this is not Dave Ramsey
telling you to go into that he's telling
you to move it because you're gonna have
to the courts gonna make use on that you
won't be in contempt of court on paying
somebody judge told you to pay that's
not a good place to be